[Music]
[Applause]
this week we got permanent sweater Oh
hard and fail and standing-room-only
taken away Tiffany oh yeah this company
they created their 100-year hoodie and
so they claim that this hoodie will last
you at least 100 years what the [ __ ]
does that matter you would die exactly
so they're saying like you know this
hoodie is made out of Kevlar material or
fiber oh my gosh and I think you oughta
talk to you know I'm just thinking that
very uncomfortable yeah well they use
other materials to that are found in
like spacesuit body armor you'll have to
carry your iron who's their target
demographic why did he do this so they
are a clothing brand that already has a
lot of cutting-edge adventure sports
clothing like you oh that looks like
grenade shaped kneepads
I want wine I knew their each other
well I [ __ ] little Dickie [ __ ]
modeling that's just my little Dickie I
thought it was a little Dickie yeah so
I'm going to show you guys a quick clip
of them testing this hoodie through all
kinds of [ __ ] here we go
oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is on the floor like the back of a
funny whoa now that's what kids need
oh no kids get torn ass jeans and ah ah
no [ __ ] your way oh wow I want that
money how much is that [ __ ] ya down I
don't know anytime that [ __ ] metal
shavings are coming at me or blowtorch
knowing your luck you would probably
fall out of the boat the way they threw
that [ __ ] sweater you probably fall
off the bike so wait if you were like
testing it on the dirt this is called
the Davis OVA yeah so why don't you
catch on fire in the ocean that's the
first commercial without a narrative or
emotional music that I'm like I'm not
gonna need that I want it they did not
have to pull my heartstrings at all I
don't even care fight on this women
wonder if that could stop a knife slash
mm-hmm they missed a few things is they
needed alternator
[Laughter]
they need to shoot a gun at it they need
to have someone [ __ ] come on it well
the color see if it stays a stain but it
just got torched yeah - long as Tom Mann
as lethal come in yeah so this clutter
is how you get your whites so clean now
this have you retailing for 294 Bailey's
wars hit 300 bucks pretty much $300 for
it to stay intact after all the [ __ ]
you're going to put it through yeah but
at the same time it just looks like a
basic guess winner could it that's what
stove about it looks basic but the
functionality do you work with them on
what gives you I'm down give me one of
those sweaters I want you the problem is
this though in today's market none of us
really hold on to [ __ ] the way it's
supposed to so no matter how much you
spend on something when the next new
team comes out everyone wants to get
that new thing because those files going
to change
Hjalmar is on yes in 10 years the stars
going to change like big-time cool thing
about a 30 though is he's always a
hoodie yeah
never goes out of style the cut changes
yep well apparently there's different
types of like hoodies but this standard
hoodie will always be around yeah I
don't know this is a fashion statement
belt but it's for comfort I don't know
if it's that comfortable I don't know we
got it we got to put it on I got to buy
just to make sure look like you're doing
because it's made out of Kevlar think it
looks to be really heavy you know what
my problem is I'll get this hoodie right
it'll be in my closet right and then
I'll go out on trips I'll go out to
places and I'll be like I don't need no
sweater that's for [ __ ] and I won't
bring it and I'll go [ __ ] it's kind of
cold and I'll go into Walmart and I'll
buy a hoodie there so two things
happened I even did that [ __ ] in Malibu
a bar bug I have so many jackets I ended
up getting a sweater because I didn't
bring a sweater on the trip yes they're
saying too much mm washes 4000 wears in
about a hundred accidents a hundred only
a hundred how about forgetfulness we
need a hoodie that could tell me hey
it's cold out tonight w [ __ ] tight
right when you walk out right you forgot
me bro q I never leave you at home no I
get that I got what I need the gay
sweater hey hey and I also say that this
sweater can withstand temperatures from
572 degrees Fahrenheit to negative 328
degrees but you are the person can't so
what does it basically saying that this
sweater can survive being on words
that's dope but you all you'll just be
dead and butter but that's cool is this
fast though it doesn't matter this is a
good decent is hoodie like I wear that
one I wonder how warm it is I just want
it for bragging rights
like I think I'll buy it and I'm
literally going to do all of those tests
to like just be like I have this jacket
look what it could do and then put it on
a motorcycle drag that [ __ ] get on the
yacht and then [ __ ] throw it that's
consumerism to the back I know what I
wish I wish they made hoodies and
jackets that don't keep you warm huh but
that'd be us oh you mean so you could
look dull Santee alley no it still keeps
you warm yeah I want to wear something
cuz I like jackets but I don't want to
sweat all day you'll make any sense you
sound like
girl right now yes done girls I'm told
um you said that Linton I just agreed
with you and I'm still in trouble I know
it's like the girls who are the what
they called the uggs and the sweaters on
top lips and the short shorts and in
your muscle boys do it - okay they do
this they do that or they were [ __ ]
scarves I don't know any guy that wears
uggs well you don't know any guy that
would even dress in that though all your
guy friends are here oh you talk about
West LA guys this is just a specific guy
I never seen guys wear Uggs though on
the street a lot of Asian guys were uh
like those [ __ ] big big odds like the
girls really yes I see those I've seen
like like I've seen the moccasins yeah
moccasin ugh I've seen ugh these are
usually of the the newly immigrated and
I got the fatal without Geo why there's
a life they're not asian-american also
okay fine I don't know I saw I saw one
of those lifetime wanting to do that the
state south of me America Rhett this
will had a white dress shirt with a
seatbelt attached to his arm and I was
like what the [ __ ] is that like it was
really a seatbelt attached and it was
like you know what though they're
probably looking at us like look at
these basic ass [ __ ] all these
Americans I'm sure they're so basic look
at me I got a peacock on my [ __ ] back
no cuz I'm trying to figure out what
brand stitched on a seat belt to a shirt
and sold that [ __ ] I don't know what
brand it is hi Jan none of those
Louboutin shoes with the [ __ ] spikes
all over that oh yeah yeah yeah looking
like [ __ ] you know who's the time
that uh yeah see my [ __ ] when eight but
when I first came out all like who the
[ __ ] is going to wear that mainland
exactly softly Matt mark you're either a
tall white girl that wrote that does
runway work or like an old rich person
with no taste
or it's [ __ ] mainlanders so for our
next story there is this man that failed
very miserably one who's trying to hide
some mouth [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you say
imma like a tree
I am alive just a tree I identify as a
tree you cannot get me to jail so first
I'm going to read you guys with the
police station wrote on the Facebook
post and then I'll show you the photo so
they wrote is a male in college or adele
who was wanted by police decided to try
to hide this morning when they went to
his property looking for him you will
not be surprised to find out that yes we
did find him he will not be winning any
awards for hide and seek championships
anytime is what he look like
where is oh my god the back where I
don't see him oh you guys are funny
house like he always ask me like where
are these oh I thought - a pleasure
walking - don't worry like where else
can I tell you what you know it's funny
my dog
does the same [ __ ] I got a picture on
Instagram of Maddie like that under my
bed hiding yeah that's so funny she's
hiding like that I didn't know that
something well could she when she gets
weepy she doesn't like the light so she
wants she wants to be under like a dark
place but she's only halfway inside like
that you think she's hiding her issues
like I'm going to do stupid [ __ ] like
that whenever my dog [ __ ] up she'll
[ __ ] run back into a cage which is a
sleeping place but sure I could tell she
[ __ ] up because she didn't cave like
this fella tense yeah you know like god
damn it you did something I'm gonna find
a little nugget somewhere oh [ __ ] your
dogs are act guilty I mean it doesn't
matter you do [ __ ] like ya did it [ __ ]
don't really do anything
Tyson was the one other troublemaker
these three are pretty much angels I
would never make eye contact you would
like as soon as you come in he's like oh
[ __ ] you would just stare at a wall now
you could clearly teletype it six years
well like this you do like looking
around you like I know we'll be wrong in
here when I saw this photo it
immediately reminded me of an Isaac was
a baby because kids do that all the time
like they think they're hiding but
they're like clearly in plain sight
my cousin was playing them hide-and-seek
with my nephew and she
sent me this picture of him behind a
pole like this he was behind a pole okay
the kids against a can't you yeah that
status' hiding place have you guys ever
played like hide and seek and then you
fell asleep at your honey singh yes all
the time
what how hired are you as a [ __ ] kid
no it's because they took forever to
find us hold on and I got a broad
daylight as a kid oh no - I was way too
energetic there's no way I'd be Heidi
Heidi I really hadn't taken mmediately
as soon as you're hiding you said I get
the P oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no no no
it's the whole did did you get nervous
yes Hartford behind you see because I
was the size of David daleiden
hmm bigger ask you a good sec yeah yeah
recently I was gonna Kiki we always like
to play hide-and-seek around the house
that one guy that's always fires not
ever nkv no we always want to be alone
tag along
Thank You taking care of my catered
Shapeways book name okay so the three of
us we like to turn off the lights around
the whole house and then we each have
flashlights and then we look for each
other and if I had to pick that way dude
I hope I'm a parent that [ __ ] you're
going to cook in and uncover a [ __ ]
ghost you don't want the light giveaway
where you're at though so the one
searching is the one with a life
gosh uh that's pretty fun yeah hope I'm
a pair like that because I feel like as
a parent of it let's play hide and seek
a get away from me really tired
hopefully I'm not that because I feel
like I feel like whitetips like in
Pasadena a super active like hey let's
let me grab the kids arm and they swing
them around and I look at myself and I
try to like envision myself in their
shoes and like Danny swing me I must
stop [ __ ] legs now what the hell is
wrong with you
just walk know you'll see so one thing
fear exactly the joy and everything
gives you energy
holy get go so it's different not know
once you're gonna be with your own kids
are gonna be so happy to see them happy
now make you happy what my kid wants to
walk and I don't want to want to walk
anymore so I still want to hold you oh
yeah can't be like that are gonna have
some skinny ass legs I would kind of
guilt trip a little bit to like myself
I'll be like no I is getting older I
don't know I feel whole I become a big I
don't give a [ __ ] ah just got to do the
opposite of this
the more you hold them the more you
patch like leg weights when they are
walking on their own they're developing
that muscle and then you could take them
off and then hold them to balance out
because it's good to be soon I think I'd
give them like another like two years I
won't be able to do this you're near
eleven yeah I don't care be the same
height at me I'd still [ __ ] hold them
to tears because it because right now he
hasn't had a major growth spurt yet so I
think it's coming soon I don't know when
so I'm just going to take it as much as
I can
oh my baby's getting big for our last
story this airline in Colombia called
Viva Colombia sell dangerous the budget
airline they have announced that they're
considering plans to remove seats from
entire aircraft oh they're just going to
send coke now you're gonna provide like
cheaper alternatives like for people I
want to travel so it's like standing
yeah oh [ __ ] and then everyone has a go
that busting no that's crazy
sounds dangerous smog that's why they're
like how long are these wet weather like
eight hours an hour flight you know cuz
it already got smaller and smaller like
the seating space from back in a day so
before we were born the standard seating
was like what first class is today
that's what the seats used to look like
I remember it now they're going to make
you stand like a Japanese train we get
[ __ ] you feel someone's crack on your
dick and someone's dick on your crack
god damn well they're saying that
they're going to try to increase you
sort of like bar stools where you kind
of lean on
not completely just a me biogenesis a do
you know someone's ass on your dick it's
just like this crack right here they
just let rest it right in between the
crack yeah like a hotdog on top of a bun
yep when you don't open the hotdog bun
but just left user rested on top of the
[ __ ] button like I said yeah so
they're saying that they want to offer
this like standing room areas in their
aircraft so then they can offer cheaper
tickets to people that want to travel
uncomfortably I don't even want that I
want regular seats and I want that
standing area to be there so we can
stretch out our [ __ ] legs yeah I like
that idea that yeah because they do that
in the business class there's a standing
area like the International there's a
bar and a standing area where you could
sit there's like there's like three
pinches in the back where you can
stretch out your legs just have a yoga
room oh yeah but that's business class
though people are paying for the comfort
now what airlines are trying to do is
discomfort with a discount oh yeah you
want to pay less you get less maybe
there are me I'm meeting Adam and oh
maybe there's a ton of people that want
to fly but they can't afford it so
they're like well what can we do to make
it really really cheap so that people
want to visit their families can because
discount airlines are making more money
than regular airlines is that a fact or
is that yes oh right now the discount
airlines in Europe they're really
killing it because what they did is I
think during the recession in the States
when there was a surplus of airplanes
they just bought those and then the old
school ones and then they rent made it
better and then they they figured out a
system where it's like they're always
making money but then the airplanes that
are not discount airlines they're not
always making money sometimes they just
lose money or whatever and all that I
just want to go fast train somewhere you
want to you want to train I want I like
trains trains are pretty dope yeah like
the ones in the movie are in Japan they
were [ __ ] comfortable as [ __ ] yeah
yet wider oh the bullet train yeah
then I'm like the other kind of change
no not that but even if we had like a
train people let's say are like metro
system in LA they [ __ ] suck yeah I
would like to have still keep the piece
of [ __ ] ones right but that's why they
pay that price and I would like for them
to make another train that's like three
times the price but has more amenities
and it's a lot cleaner take the art go
aren't they trying to fill the train
that goes from here to like San
Francisco I'm like like ten for ten
years in ours or something if they can
make that within like the next ten years
though I'll be very happy because I'm
still young at that point on the foot
that's still dope I'll still be able to
expense to be happy yeah that's what
they're trying to do with this airline
thing they're trying to provide
something for people to be able to
afford and they have to just put up with
whatever they have to put up with and
then if you want a little bit more
amenities at the same orange I think
Elon Musk is already billed as being the
tunnel for the LA yeah I started that's
[ __ ] great holiday somewhere so it
could ease up traffic so that people can
go under and above what cars yeah you
trying to get rid of le traffic that's
all so [ __ ] rich you could think
things and it'll just happen what a cool
guy nothing's [ __ ] crazy man I have a
way easier way to get rid of LA traffic
perch exactly why are you working so
hard well there's already like ten
million people here we could do with
like two million you know you're not
going to be one of the ones because I'm
the one that's spreading the diseases I
have [ __ ] Anatole Jerry solid success
I don't like my voice didn't even go up
to show it's a question dude that shit's
[ __ ] crazy though man did you see on
4th of July it was the first time I saw
my map in my car all green there was no
red anywhere yeah it was [ __ ] night I
went to Mario's place and [ __ ] 50 I
thought there was going to be so much
traffic but I was at a dog beach and
like 40 minutes that she takes me an
hour everybody's just having barbecues
at home oh yeah it was awesome
there was only traffic towards the
nighttime after at night it was kind of
bad yeah but did you see how it looked
like fog because of yeah I dude I kept
sure and like it was like World War 3
I just heard bombs going all over kind
of radio sort of freaking out Oh
are they fun and meatloaf or cool before
using that means for years to come they
do some [ __ ] yeah bring it on the verge
of season again Oh No hey guys thanks
for watching our last video make sure to
follow us on instagram @ JK films to
watch more videos right up there
[Music]